well we've just heard from the Prime
Minister Rishi sunx speaking after a
busy day yesterday his tax returns
obviously were released and that Windsor
framework vote let's have a listen to
what he had to say I was really pleased
yesterday that there was very strong
support for the Windsor framework and
that's because it's the right deal for
Northern Ireland it's good for families
for people for businesses for
communities across Northern Ireland it
restores the balance in the Belfast Good
Friday agreement secures Northern
Ireland's place in our precious Union
and make sure that Northern Ireland has
proper sovereignty you know that's why
it's a good deal I'm pleased that it
commanded broad support and we can look
forward to a better and brighter future
you paid about 22 percent in Combined
tax on your income and capital gains is
that fair or should capital gains tax be
higher well I you know I said I would
publish my tax returns I was pleased to
be able to do that yesterday in the
interest of transparency and and the
most important thing is what am I doing
to help people of this country with the
cost of living that's their number one
priority that's why the beginning of the
year I set out five priorities the first
of those was to harm inflation and the
budget recently extended our support for
People's Energy bills just to remind
everyone you know I took a decision to
tax the windfall profits of big energy
companies 75 tax rate on those and we're
using that money to help pay for around
half of everyone's Energy bill over this
winter it's worth 1 500 pounds that's
the actions of this government that's
what we're doing